And I'd like to leave you with this thought.
On the left is water coming through the shore,
taken from a NASA satellite.
On the right, there is a coral.
Now if you take the mammary gland and spread it
and take the fat away, on a dish it looks like that.
Do they look the same? Do they have the same patterns?
Why is it that nature keeps doing that over and over again?
And I'd like to submit to you
that we have sequenced the human genome,
we know everything about the sequence of the gene,
the language of the gene, the alphabet of the gene,
But we know nothing, but nothing,
about the language and alphabet of form.
So, it's a wonderful new horizon,
it's a wonderful thing to discover for the young
and the passionate old, and that's me.
So go to it!
(Applause)